in the last lesson I brought up the
concept of the verb as a function word
that has a number of different arguments
we didn't really go into the
implications of that statement but we'll
start to unravel it this time like other
verbs give has a number of slots that
take a certain number of nouns or
pronouns giv has three of those slots to
be specific it expects three arguments
so I give it to him
makes sense but I gave it kind of with
holds information we're expecting and I
gave leaves us with two slots that are
not filled as I described before those
slots are filled by arguments which are
nouns and pronouns now let's talk about
the number of those arguments verbs can
be described by their valency which is a
fancy way of talking about the number of
arguments that a verb requires valency
is specific to a single verb a verb like
run expects one argument the subject so
it's called mono valent divalent verbs
expect to like the verb see I see it she
saw them trivalent verbs include give as
in I gave it to him the labels
monovalent divalent and trivalent depend
on the core arguments the arguments that
are required for normal use of the verb
in question we can of course add extras
in the form of adjuncts she saw it on
Thursday she saw it on Thursday with her
brother etc we can look at it another
way by focusing on transitivity
transitivity considers what type of
objects the verb takes transitive verbs
take a direct object I say John sees her
because si takes a direct object in this
case her intransitive verbs do not take
a direct object you would say I slept
but probably not
I slept then because sleep is an
intransitive verb
we can make a further distinction
between intransitive verbs and Dai
transitive verbs I gave it to him as
both a direct object and an indirect
object so it's a Dai transitive verb
defective verbs are a curious class and
they include verbs with only one fairly
meaningless phenomenal subject that
subject fills a grammatical function the
so called whether verbs are great
examples it rains it snows it Hales
those all have a subject it that we
don't switch out for another subject
like Steve snows the pronoun it is a
dummy pronoun that just stands in the
slot simply because we expect to have a
subject this isn't a full-fledged
argument here so when it comes to
valency we call these a valent verbs
that's a good way to start thinking
about the number of arguments that a
verb has come around next time we're
going to start discussing the type of
arguments
you